eine abenteuerreise durch polen und die
baltischen länder mit dem elektroauto
meine mission herausfinden wie es um die
energiewende im osten europas steht
vorbei an rauchenden ungetüm durch
radioaktive strahlung
[Musik]
fahrerlose fahrzeuge die meinem weg
vollsten
und immer wieder unendliche weiten mit
wäldern seenlandschaften
und stränden
anderthalb tausend kilometer von clash
of in polen bis nach tallinn im norden
estlands saubere energie aus sonne wind
und wasser klimaneutralität bis 2050 das
will der green deal der europäischen
union aber ist das zu schaffen
nachhaltigkeit und osteuropa passt das
zusammen
[Musik]
meine reise beginnt mitten in einer
mondlandschaft geschaffen von
menschenhand schon aus der ferne sind
die kühltürme des kohlekraftwerk wer tut
gut zu sehen
genährt von der braunkohle aus dem
angrenzenden tagebau der größte
kohlendioxid emittent auf dem kontinent
der superlativ der polnischen
energieversorgung selbst im
miniaturformat wirkt er gewaltig das
kraftwerk liefert energie für elf
millionen haushalte bis zu 22 prozent
des landesweiten energiebedarf
es spielt eine schlüsselrolle für unsere
energiesicherheit und dann darf ich die
turbinenhalle des kraftwerks besichtigen
heiß und laut ist es hier mehr als 5000
megawatt gesamtleistung erzeugt der
stelle eine riesen
im kontrollraum herrscht konzentrierte
gelassenheit ihre arbeit werden die
ingenieure hier wohl bis zur rente
behalten
doch spätestens 2036 ist schluss dann
geht der letzte block vom netz wir alle
wissen in welche richtung sich die
energie in polen und in der europäischen
union bewegen wird
jedem ist bewusst auch uns als
energiekonzern dass die ehre der kohle
früher oder später vorbei ist nun aber
endet mein besuch im kraftwerk mit dem
elektroauto in den nächstgelegenen out
der erste eindruck überrascht gepflegte
grün und sportanlagen ein modernes
spaßbad ausladen der architektur das
kraftwerk bringt kleschtschow üppige
gewerbesteuereinnahmen solarpanel auf
der rückseite der parkbank außerdem
usb-anschluss kontaktloses aufladen fürs
handy das ganze super bequem was will
man mehr
selbst touristen will man in zukunft
nach kleschtschow flocken kohleausstieg
nein danke kraftwerk ist doch unsere
nährende mutter dank des tagebaus dank
des kraftwerkes atmen die menschen hier
anders es liebt sich einfach besser
widerspruch kommt nur von wenigen
matschie corsa kieritzsch engagiert sich
in einer umweltinitiative und macht sich
keine illusionen um die kohle zu
ersetzen müsse man den menschen hier
alternativen bieten eine zukunft können
dieser region nur innovative ideen
bringen wie wasserkraft oder klein
energieanlagen eine grüne wirtschaft auf
der basis des europäischen green deal
politiker
und dann gibt mir maciej noch einen tipp
ich solle das kohle museum besuchen um
zu verstehen warum die widerstände gegen
europas klimapläne hier so gewaltig sind
seit über 20 millionen jahren gibt es
rundum class schiff braunkohle seit gut
60 jahren wird sie in der region
gefördert
es ist die last der tradition die schwer
auf die gegenwart rückt und jetzt
klimaneutral bis 2050 wie soll das zu
schaffen sein
die eu sollte uns vor allem mehr zeit
geben damit wir unsere wirtschaft auf
andere energieträger umstellen können 50
jahre kommunismus haben unsere chancen
im vergleich zu anderen eu ländern
verschlechtert
wie die zukunft der region nach der
kohle aussehen könnte hat das museum in
pappmaché modelliert naherholung stadt
tagebau windräder photovoltaik tourismus
die langfristige vision für 2055 ein
weiter weg bis dahin
für mich noch 1500 km bis tallinn mit
dem elektroauto dessen reichweite
deutlich geringer als beim verbrennen
wir schon darauf hin dass der akku zur
neige geht also es wird höchste zeit die
nächste ladesäule anzusteuern
[Musik]
zwischenstopp im nordosten polens marcin
beträgt eigentlich ein gartencenter
setzt mit ladesäulen für e autos aber
auf einen wachstumsmarkt
unsere ladesäule war lange zeit die
einzige zwischen warschau und kaunas in
litauen
inzwischen gibt es mehr sollen aber wir
wollen hier im nordosten polens ein
eigenes ladenetz aufbauen den strom der
aus den ladesäulen kommt produziert
maschinen mit seiner eigenen
photovoltaikanlage noch hält sich die
nachfrage in grenzen
die autos sind teuer und die
ladeinfrastruktur in polen bescheiden
vom staat gibt es kaum finanzielle
unterstützung aber maschinen setzt
ohnehin auf eigene initiative
polen polen wollen viele menschen die
initiative übernehmen wenn die regierung
ihnen keine steine in den weg legt dann
wird man sich für e mobilität und
klimaschutz einsetzen
dafür sind wir ein gutes beispiel
inzwischen handelt maschinen mit seinen
selbst entwickelten ladesäulen er glaubt
an die grüne zukunft seines landes auch
wenn es wohl länger dauern wird
polen und die energiewende das kann doch
eine erfolgsgeschichte werden wenn das
land eine vergangenheit hinter sich
lässt
an der die regierung noch immer fest
hält die vorboten dieser zeit sind
unübersehbar
mit diesen eindrücken im gepäck mache
ich mich weiter auf den weg gen norden
mit dem auto über die grenze nach
litauen
ohne kontrolle polens nachbar gehört zum
schengen raum
die zweite etappe beginnt in groß
kienitz und führt mich bis biaggi das
[Musik]
todeschini unverwechselbarer name für
eine unverwechselbare stadt litauens
vorzeige kurort hat alles zu bieten was
erholungsbedürftige suchen seit dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert kommen gäste um
sich in mineralbäder zu regenerieren das
quellwasser salzig aber äußerst gesund
ein elektroauto braucht jetzt etwas
anderes strom aus der ladesäule eines
hotels warum werde ich hier finde ich
meine frage es war tatsächlich die erste
dieser art im baltikum erklärt paulus
flug hauskaufs und führt mich dann durch
sein ökohotel der strom zu 100 prozent
grün und selbst produziert die
appartements im winter geheizt mit
geothermie die wärme kommt aus 80 metern
tiefe gut gedämmte häuser viel holz und
alle stoffe aus umweltfreundlichem
leinen
ich würde nie so tun als hätte ich die
grüne agenda erfunden aber ich müsste
doch blind sein wenn ich nicht sehen
würde was in der welt vor sich geht
ich glaube die welt wie nachhaltiger
werden und litauen ist da keine ausnahme
der außenpool wird im winter mit holz
geheizt litauen sid paulus auf einem
guten weg zu den europäischen klimaziele
auch weil man von russischem gas
unabhängig werden
[Musik]
das ist vielen ein ansporn mehr
alternative energiequellen zu nutzen
damit verändern wir die art und weise
wie wir unsere häuser beheizen
abfahrt ausdruck kiening und hinein in
litauens weitläufige wege quelle einer
der schnellsten energie umstellungen
europas von fossilen zu erneuerbaren
litauen gehört vor allem holz dazu damit
speist man hier einen großen teil seiner
fernwärme und das land hat noch viel
mehr zu bieten
wilde beinahe unberührten natur
erfrischende badeseen dörfer wie aus der
zeit gefallen
ein e auto aber kann man nur in der
stadt aufladen zwischenstopp in vilnius
litauen energiewende aber muss ein
schweres erbe überwinden das
atomkraftwerk ignalina ein meiler vom
gleichen typ wie calvin besichtigung nur
mit schutzanzug und dann auf einen zwei
kilometer langen fußmarsch durch
scheinbar endlose tunnel
die strahlung in der reaktorhülle erhöht
aber unbedenklich die brennstäbe im
abklingbecken außer betrieb
wir haben alles unter kontrolle
es ist unsere aufgabe die gefahr zu
minimieren und uns an sämtliche auflagen
zu halten unsere arbeit wird von den
behörden ständig überwacht 2009 wurden
die beiden reaktoren abgeschaltet das
war europas bedingung für litauens eu
beitritt seitdem haben sie hier viel
erfahrung beim rückbau gesammelt das
know-how wollen sie nun gewinnbringend
weiterverkaufen
früher haben fast 6000 leute eben akw
gearbeitet weniger als ein drittel ist
übrig geblieben
2036 soll das kraftwerk komplett
demontiert sein
bis dahin bleibt direktor autos kam
jener der oberste abreise auch wenn er
hier lieber atomstrom als verstrahlten
bauschutt produzieren würde es ist nicht
traurig es sind neue herausforderungen
denen sich bisher niemand stellen musste
ein sehr interessanter job vor den toren
des meilers ist in den 1970 er jahren
eine sowjetische plan stadt entstanden
visaginas gebaut für die arbeiter und
ihre familien als hier noch strom
produziert wurde weil das hier der
überdimensionale geigerzähler für die
stadt wie viel strahlung heute hier
ankommt wird zumindest nicht mehr
angezeigt
ginge es nach den einwohnern das
kernkraftwerk in ihrer nähe berenyi
abgeschaltet worden nun aber stehen die
stadt und ihre verantwortlichen vor
einer jahrhundertaufgabe
wir müssen eine neue identität finden
was können wir aus der stadt machen
die vision heißt tourismus bisher
verirren sich nur einige hundert
besucher pro jahr nach wie chinas in
zukunft will man gezielt um sie werben
ist eine kombination aus verschiedenen
bereichen natur tourismus die alte
industriearchitektur des akw das alles
macht visaginas interessant litauen ist
bereit für den sprung in die zukunft die
atomkraft musste man europa zuliebe
hinter sich lassen nun setzt das land
auf heimische ressourcen wälder wind und
wasser
mein auto aber fährt mit strom immer
rechtzeitig den akku aufladen in diesem
teil europas eine herausforderung genau
wie die energiewende selbst ist europa
bereit dafür
anderthalb tausend kilometer von polen
bis in die estnische hauptstadt tallinn
meine dritte etappe führt mich durch
lettland von riga bis nach bern
[Musik]
lettlands ostseeküste ein paradies für
strandurlauber und ein segen für
menschen die mit batteriebetriebenen
autos unterwegs sind
[Applaus]
hier kann man den akku seines
elektroautos aufladen und ein bisschen
auch den eigenen
das baltische land am meer sieht sich
als vorreiter in sachen energiewende
der anteil der erneuerbaren schon jetzt
bei 40 prozent
knapp die hälfte davon aus wasserkraft
erste station auf meiner heutigen etappe
eine mühle in der nähe von riga hier hat
office hennings den hut auf der
pensionierte ingenieur hat die
getreidemühle vor 30 jahren gekauft und
in mühsamer kleinarbeit wieder aufgebaut
korn mahlen hat er aufgegeben aber strom
aus wasserkraft produziert er immer noch
wasserkraft es sauberer energie grüne
energie
sie trägt nicht zur erderwärmung bei und
das ist meines erachtens die hauptsache
das ist in diesen zeiten das wichtigste
den stromgenerator hat orwells nach
lettland eu-beitritt angeschafft mit
fördergeldern aus brüssel zwischen
300.000 und 500.000 kilowattstunden
produziert er damit jedes jahr genug um
hunderte haushalte in der region zu
versorgen
es müsste mehr staatliche unterstützung
sei es in form von direktzahlungen die
es zum teil heute schon gibt und dann
aber die möglichkeit den strom zu
verkaufen ohne zusätzliche gebühren
zahlen zu müssen wenn man strom ins netz
einspeist als orwells anfing hat er mit
der kleinen wasserkraft gutes geld
verdient heute fühlt sich der 75-jährige
von abgaben förmlich erdrückt trotzdem
machte erst mal weiter so beständig wie
der börse fluss dessen wasser die
turbine antreibt
tradition und moderne gehen in lettland
hand in hand öl und gas bleiben wichtig
für die energieversorgung die zukunft
aber gehört dem wasser die ressource
über die die letten reichlich verfügen
in den köpfen der jungen leute hat
klimaschutz priorität
ja wir reden auch in unserer familie
darüber
wir denken darüber nach ein haus zu
bauen überlegen wie wir es mit grüner
energie versorgen
ob es überhaupt möglich ist wie viel es
kosten wird und ob wir uns das leisten
können lettland ist bereits jetzt
relativ grün weil wir keine großen
produzenten sind die meisten co2
emissionen werden von privaten
haushalten verursacht von den
verbrauchern
unsere industrie ist ja nicht so groß
und nicht nur das für die letten auf die
überholspur der energiewende
die drei großen wasserkraftwerke stammen
noch aus sowjetischer zeit in
regenreichen jahren liefern sie 80
prozent des lettischen strombedarf um
europas klimaziele zu erreichen braucht
lettland aber noch mehr energieeffizienz
um den anteil fossiler brennstoffe zu
verringern und den der erneuerbaren
auszuweiten und der energieverbrauch im
transportwesen und bei
mehrfamilienhäusern reduziert werden
diese ziele verfolgen wir und so planen
wir auch der wille ist also da der weg
zum co2 freien leben und wirtschaften
dennoch weit
ich denke dass lettland ohne europas
hilfe höchstwahrscheinlich nicht in der
lage ist bis 2050 klimaneutral zu werden
wild hennings hat seinen beitrag
geleistet und viel geld in die kleine
wasserkraft investiert rentiert hat sie
sich nicht
nun will er seine mühle verkaufen und in
eine stadtwohnung ziehen sein urteil
über lettlands energiewende ernüchtert
ich denke wir liegen weit zurück um ein
jahrzehnt
allein was die modernisierung des
straßenverkehrs den schadstoffausstoß im
transportwesen angeht da werden wir
nicht vorankommen wenn unsere regierung
nicht aktiver wird
abschied von orwells und die letzten
kilometer über staubige pisten der sonne
entgegen
in estland wird sie eine wichtige rolle
spielen
was für ein tagesausklang ein lettlands
wunderschöner ostseeküste
meine nächste und letzte etappe wird
nicht bis ans ziel meiner reise führen
nach tallinn
sie beginnt in pärnu estland
sommerhauptstadt schon morgens um neun
nehmen einheimische und urlauber sein
erstes bad im meer die ostseeküste im
süden des landes wirkt beinahe
mediterranen hier an den breiten
sandstrand von pernod mit unglaublich
feinem sand kommen aus allen
landesteilen um sich im sommer zu
erholen
heil und seebad war pernod bereits im
neunzehnten jahrhundert magnet für
kurgäste ist die stadt noch heute
gründerzeit und jugendstil die altstadt
zeugt vom reichtum vergangener tage mich
aber interessiert vor allem estland
ideenreichtum in sachen energiewende das
unbemannte vehikel ist ein prototyp und
leichtgewicht künstliche intelligenz die
halt macht vor menschlicher er stoppt
[Musik]
um eine pizza auszuliefern braucht man
ihr eigentlich kein tonnen schweres auto
wir setzen darauf das fahrzeug möglichst
leicht zu gestalten
es soll wenig energie verbrauchen das
hilft klimaneutralität zu erreichen
für estland hat das gefährt bereits eine
zulassung ab übernächstem jahr soll es
in serie produziert werden
sobald alle sicherheits prüfungen
bestanden sind das hier ist kein
simulator sondern der kontroll platz von
dem aus die selbstfahrenden paket autos
überwacht werden und wenn irgendwas
schiefgeht dann drückt der kontrolleur
einfach hier auf diesen roten knopf ob
als lebensmittel lieferant mobile
eisdiele oder paketbote dass strom
betriebene fahrzeug an dem
verwendungszweck angepasst werden
auch auf estnischen straßen noch ein
fremdkörper und so ein hingucker
ist doch vernünftig dass solche autos
herumfahren
man muss keine großen fahrzeuge
benutzten um sachen auszuliefern ich
dachte was sind wir jetzt wirklich schon
in der zukunft angekommen selbst fahren
autos was kommt als nächstes
die letzten meter bis zum kunden
auslieferung direkt an der
bordsteinkante bis zu 200 kilo kann das
fahrzeug transportieren immer überwacht
von mitarbeitern in der zentrale
wir glauben dass unsere entwicklung in
die richtige richtung geht dass unsere
fahrzeuge nicht zu 100 sondern nur zu 95
prozent autonom fahren für uns war dies
die richtige entscheidung
estland musterland des digitalen
fortschritts entsprechend hoch der
stromverbrauch
immer wieder sollen solarzellen meinen
weg nach tallinn und doch gehört estland
zu den großen co2 emittenten in europa
gerade im verkehr
[Musik]
elektroautos sind immer noch ziemlich
teuer und wenn es wie jetzt kaum
staatliche zuschüsse gibt dann werden
die leute nicht von herkömmlichen
verbrennern auf e autos umsteigen in
tallinn fahren die busse inzwischen mit
gas wie scooter überall in der stadt und
vereinzelt ein transportmittel das auf
den ersten blick wie ein normales
fahrrad aussieht djokovic hatte mit zwei
freunden entwickelt
ursprünglich an freizeitprojekt in der
heimischen garage inzwischen ein
leuchtendes beispiel für estlands weg in
die elektromobilität
diese technologie macht es zum fahrrad
des einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts jeder
kann es fahren das ist sicher leicht zu
handhaben man kann längere strecken
damit zurücklegen das alles schneller
und ohne zu schwitzen nur 17 kilo wiegt
das elektrobike die batterie
diebstahlsicher im rahmen versteckt der
elektromotor an der hinterachse verstaut
eine neue generation von e bikes die
mehr menschen motivieren soll
umzusteigen
wenn nur jeder zehnte ein e bike fahren
würde statt ein neues auto zu kaufen
dann wäre der positive klimaeffekte
riesig und wenn es uns gelingt ein
gemeinschaftsgefühl zu erzeugen dann
werden immer mehr leute mitmachen
eine woche lang bin ich durch polen und
die baltischen länder gefahren heute
wissen wie die energiewende im osten
europas vorankommt
mein eindruck am ende dieser reise ja
viele menschen hier sind bereit alte
gewohnheiten aufzugeben ihre mobilität
zu verändern aber nicht wenn sie das
gefühl haben sie allein müssten die
kosten der energiewende tag
ob europa bis 2050 klimaneutral wird
hängt nicht nur vom politischen willen
ab es wird darauf ankommen die menschen
mitzunehmen